what is the determinant of a matrix this
is clearly one of the most important
topics in matrices and we need to
understand it really well how do we
write the determinant of matrix a it's
written like this a between two vertical
bars this is the determinant of a do not
confuse this with the absolute value
every matrix has a determinant and it's
unique the determinant of a matrix is a
unique number which can be calculated
it's special because it has a wide range
of applications we can use it to find
the area of a triangle the inverse of a
matrix or even to solve linear equations
if you remember we had used elementary
operations to solve for the inverse of a
matrix and the procedure was super
lending and determinants make it super
easy if we have a matrix a its
determinant is written like this the
elements will be written between the two
vertical bars and the last thing we need
to know about the determinant of a
matrix is that it can calculate only
square matrices yes it'll work only for
matrices of the order one by one two by
two three by three and so on
but how do we calculate the determinant
of a matrix we will cover that in the
next part of the lesson